vamos a repasar lo que hemos hecho hasta
ahorita pues creo que revisar el proceso
una vez más va a hacer que nos volvamos
expertos en el dibujo en los bancos en
un orden distinto en esta ocasión pero
igual simplemente es un repaso este es
un banco con poquitas reservas
de hecho dibuje sus reservas en color
verde y podemos pensarlas pues ya sea
como notas bancarias del banco central o
bien las podemos pensar como cuentas de
cheques igual en el banco central este
es otro banco y como ves este tiene un
poco más de reservas en el vídeo pasado
dije que estoy dibujando ahora las
reservas arriba verdad en la parte de
arriba de los activos esto es para que
podamos compararlas directamente con los
pasivos del banco casi todos los bancos
tienen otro tipo de pasivos pero ahorita
estoy suponiendo que todos son cuentas
de cheques y las pinte en morado
finalmente el capital lo pinté en azul
entonces esto de aquí es el capital
y por supuesto ya sea que éstas sean
notas bancarias del banco central o bien
que sean cuentas de depósito en el banco
central pues en cualquier caso son un
pasivo para el banco central para el
banco de la reserva déjame dibujar una
línea para separarlo entonces estoy aquí
es un pasivo para el banco de la reserva
un pasivo si estoy aquí fueran cuentas
si fueran cuentas de cheques en el banco
de la reserva central entonces podríamos
separarlas por banco ya sabes este banco
tiene cierta cantidad sin creo que con
ese color no se ve muy bien
este banco tiene este tanto este banco
tiene este otro tanto pero como todo
viene de la reserva federal en realidad
viene en el mismo lugar
ahora lo que aprendimos en el vídeo
pasado es que el banco de la reserva
central no dice sabes que yo quiero que
la oferta de dinero en este momento sea
equis o sea o una cantidad fija más bien
de lo que usualmente hablan es de
establecer ciertas tasas así y ciertas
tasas de interés por ejemplo la tasa
objetivo o la tasa de la reserva federal
va entonces vamos a repasar una vez más
la mecánica de cómo las transacciones en
el mercado abierto ayudan a alcanzar
estas tasas
entonces supongamos que en el día 1 este
banco de acá así antes de que pase
cualquier cosa este banco tiene más
reservas y el otro banco tiene menos
reservas entonces hay varias cosas que
este banco puede hacer con esas reservas
de más por ejemplo podría ser más
préstamos no sé déjame suponer que el
banco inicialmente tenía tenía un
coeficiente un coeficiente de reserva
del 20 por ciento si del 20% la razón
entre la reserva y el pasivo es de 20
por ciento y no sé a lo mejor las
reservas pueden bajar
15 el banco se siente cómodo con eso
entonces pues como un cuarto de sus
reservas podrían usarse en algo más
entonces en que podríamos utilizar esta
porción de las reservas pues una idea es
prestarle a otro banco verdad podría ser
este cachito de acá y a lo mejor el
banco necesita un préstamo y podría
pintarlo por aquí en el vídeo pasado
puse las reservas aquí abajito pero eso
estaba mal en realidad nos reemplazan a
otros activos entonces debía haberlas
puesto hasta arriba pero ahorita hueso
otra opción que tiene el banco en vez de
prestarle al banco es hacer más
préstamos a emprendedores y como hace
esto pues ya sabemos abriendo cuentas
bancarias como lo hemos visto en otros
vídeos con esto dicho supongamos que
observa ve este de aquí necesita dinero
y el de acá está dispuesto a prestar
pero claro no es su única opción como ya
lo dije podría haber abrir más cuentas
de cheques ahora supongamos que en el
sistema bancario actual las tasas de
interés están en pues déjame escribir
eso la tasa actual de interés
tasa actual de interés es 6%
ahora supongamos que el banco de la
reserva federal se da cuenta que no hay
suficiente oferta de dinero en el
mercado y quiere cambiar esto sin
embargo pues no va a poner un titular en
el periódico que diga no sé vamos a
pasar de 15 mil millones de pesos a 20
mil millones de pesos no ponen eso más
bien dicen que quieren bajar la tasa de
fondos federales a 35 por ciento
entonces quieren cambiar la tasa de
fondos federales lo escribo la tasa de
fondos federales
entonces están estableciendo la tasa
federal a 5% o sea así la mesa directiva
del banco de méxico undiano se sale su
presidente y dice hey sabes que yo
quiero que la tasa de fondos federales
sea 5% esta es una tasa objetivo esta
tasa de aquí es una tasa objetivo
entonces en el fondo lo que están
diciendo lo que dice la mesa directiva
es que va a realizar operaciones en el
mercado abierto de forma que ahora este
banco le preste a este banco no a 6%
sino a 5%
otra forma de pensarlo es que van a
realizar operaciones en el mercado
abierto de tal modo que la demanda de
reservas también disminuya así este
banco va a querer pagar menos porque le
presten dinero no sé antes aceptaba un
6% y ahora sólo va a poder aceptar con
5% y recuerda en cualquier transacción
ambas partes deben de estar de acuerdo
con el trato va entonces como le hace el
banco de méxico pues creo que ya más o
menos estamos acostumbrados número uno
va a imprimir billetes
va a imprimir algunos billetes hasta
ahorita estos billetes son activos
porque no los han utilizado para nada
eso es activo y por supuesto tiene un
pasivo correspondiente lo voy a hacer
con otro tono de verde y el pasivo
correspondiente es notas bancarias
pendientes debe haber hecho desde el
principio esto en un tono más obscuro
los pasivos los activos están en color
verde claro ahora lo que el banco
federal va a hacer y es tiene mucho
sentido porque no quieren volverse un
banco insolvente de hecho quieren
invertir así en cosas muy muy seguras
después hablaremos un poco más de esto
pero bueno lo que dicen en lo siguiente
voy a tomar este dinero que imprimí y
voy a inyectar dinero en el sistema
bancario comprando pagarés del gobierno
y esos pagarés no tienen por qué
comprarse los al gobierno podrían
comprarse lo pues no sé a mi abuelita oa
china o al vendedor de la esquina o no
sea el chavo del ocho' a quien sea a
quién tenga esos pagarés por el momento
vamos a ponerlo así simple y vamos a
suponer que es alguien de mexico no sé
digamos mi tío déjame ver si puedo
dibujar por aquí a mi tío
este es mi tío y ahorita tiene un pagaré
del gobierno
un pagaré del gobierno ok entonces él no
quería vender su pagaré sin embargo
ahorita el banco federal ya imprimió un
montón de billetes más entonces pues él
no quería vender su pagaré para seguir
ganando interés pero dice a lo mejor si
alguien me pagará un poco más de lo que
vale pues si me animo a venderlo y
entonces el banco federal ha emitido no
sabe qué es el banco federal
de hecho permitió nada más sabe que se
le está vendiendo al mercado abierto
justo como pasa cuando se venden
acciones lo que sucede visto desde
afuera es que emitió ve que hay alguien
quién sabe quién que quiere comprar
pagarés del tesoro pues a un muy buen
precio a un precio que está bueno
entonces mi tío dice que sabes que si lo
voy a vender se lo voy a vender a esa
persona incógnita y al final de cuentas
resulta que esta persona incógnita es el
banco de la reserva y entonces ahora el
banco de la reserva tiene sabes que yo
creo que mi tío sería un inversionista
bien famosos y tan solo el banco de la
reserva le comprará
bueno entonces vende su pagaré del
gobierno entonces pues ya no tiene un
pagaré de gobierno y que recibe a cambio
es el banco de la reserva le da un
billete de 100 pesos o miles de millones
de billetes de 100 pesos
o tal vez le abre una cuenta en el banco
de la reserva pero sabes que para
mantenernos con los pies en la tierra
vamos a pensar que lo cambia todo por
billetes entonces ahora tiene billetes
de pesos y que va a ser con esos miles
de millones de billetes de pesos pues
obvio no los va a vender en su colchón
los va a meter en el sistema bancario va
entonces tal vez le da un poquito a este
banco de acá y tendría que poner esos
nuevos activos acá arriba ahí fue donde
me equivoqué en el vídeo pasado porque
no estamos reemplazando activos sino
adquiriendo nuevos entonces supongamos
que mi tío puso un poquito de su dinero
aquí después de vender sus pagarés y
supongamos que puso el resto por acá yo
no sé a lo mejor son los tíos de muchas
personas déjame cambiar otra vez de tono
de verde no sabes qué mejor lo voy a
poner en azul para que veamos qué es un
depósito nuevo si el azul y el verde se
parecen bueno creo que ves la idea y
claro ahora el banco también tiene un
pasivo correspondiente
que pues puede ser una nueva cuenta de
cheques emitido todavía no tiene deja le
añado un poquito por aquí ahí está ahora
que empieza a pasar en el sistema
bancario con respecto a los préstamos
pues de repente este banco ahora tiene
más dinero aumentaron sus activos y
también aumentaron un poco sus pasivos
si verdad sí pues claro sus activos
aumentaron tanto como haya depositado mi
tío y pues de modo similar como le
abrieron una cuenta de cheques también
su pasivo aumentó en esta misma cantidad
al final de cuentas el coeficiente de
reserva acaba aumentando si tomas la
razón la razón de esta altura
a esta altura entonces ahora va a
aumentar esa razón entonces ahora no
necesita este banco esté acá no necesita
tanto dinero para mejorar su coeficiente
de reserva y de modo similar el otro
banco que ya tenía un coeficiente de
reserva muy bueno que ya tenía reservas
de más ahora tiene todavía más reservas
este banco tiene una demanda más baja de
reservas y este otro tiene una oferta
más grande entonces el banco de acá ya
nada más va a estar dispuesto a pagar
una tasa de interés más
porque ya no le urge tanto y por otro
lado el banco de acá le urge prestar
porque porque ahora tiene un montón de
reservas y no le gusta que se queden ahí
en sus bóvedas por esta razón va a estar
dispuesto a cobrar una tasa más baja
entonces está bien padre tan solo
aumentando o disminuyendo las reservas
del banco federal si hace las cosas bien
puedes disminuir la tasa de préstamo a
5% si la tasa sólo baja a 5.5 entonces
el banco federal puede seguir haciendo
esto hasta llegar al objetivo y si se le
pasa la mano digamos a 4.5 entonces
puede vender los pagarés de gobierno con
esto revertiría el efecto y entonces
disminuiría la cantidad de reservas pero
una cosa que quiero dejar bien clara es
que estas operaciones aunque en el fondo
afecten la tasa de fondos federales que
pues es el objetivo público del banco de
méxico estas operaciones tienen el
efecto neto de aumentar la capacidad de
préstamos de los bancos y si tenemos un
coeficiente de reserva no sé del 10 por
ciento entonces cada peso que inyecte en
el sistema cada peso que metas al
sistema bancario
digamos aquí le permite hacer al banco
hasta otros 10 pesos en préstamos y
supongamos que se lo presta todo a este
banco entonces ahora se convierte en un
activo que es un préstamo para el banco
de acá de modo que ahora este banco
tiene un préstamo que le hizo el otro
esto de aquí ya no es una cuenta de
cheques sino el préstamo que le visual
el otro banco acaba teniendo más
reservas estas son sus reservas que creo
que más bien debería haber puesto en
verde pero lo importante es que no
importa donde terminen estas reservas no
importa en qué bóvedas se queden
finalmente esas nuevas reservas por cada
peso que metimos permiten otros 10 pesos
de préstamo este banco ahora puede crear
10 pesos en cuentas de cheques a través
de préstamos verdad
y entonces aunque el banco de la reserva
federal se la pase hablando de tasas de
interés y bueno después voy a hacer otro
vídeo para explicar por qué hacen esto
pero bueno aunque se la pase hablando de
tasas de interés al realizar estas
operaciones en el mercado abierto que
son operaciones que incrementan la
oferta y por tanto si baja en la tasa de
interés en realidad en el fondo lo que
están haciendo es aumentar la capacidad
de préstamo de los bancos entonces la
cantidad de reservas es dinero base que
también ya vimos que podemos pensar como
como los pasivos del banco central eso
de ahí es el dinero base m 0 y obtuvimos
un efecto multiplicador para m 1 la
cantidad de dinero que el banco puede
prestar por lo que ya platicamos verdad
hay más reservas entonces hay más
préstamos entonces a lo que el banco
central se refiere con disminuir la tasa
de interés es que van a realizar
operaciones en el mercado abierto para
aumentar las reservas del sistema
bancario entonces está padres se
pudieron mantener los coeficientes de
reserva pero se incrementó la capacidad
de préstamo de los bancos y por tanto el
dinero base y el dinero con las otras
definiciones que teníamos nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo